as we all know Netflix giveth and
Netflix taketh away and lo and behold
it's taking away quite a few really
great flicks during March 2020 it can be
difficult to keep track of all the
comings and goings on Netflix but
fortunately for you
we're on top of it most of Marvel
Studios releases have already boogied
off of Netflix and onto their new home
on rival streamer Disney Plus and the
stragglers won't be around for long as
of now you can still catch Avengers
infinity war ant-man in the wasp and
black panther on Netflix but if you're
keen to relive King two challahs awesome
2018 solo adventure you'd better do it
pretty soon time's running out so don't
freeze star chadwick boseman gives a
powerful regal performance his co-stars
Danai gurira and Letitia Wright deliver
star making turns and Michael B Jordan
brings to life one of the marvel
cinematic universes most complex
villains to date Black Panther is one of
mighty Marvel's greatest films and that
is really saying something stream it on
Netflix until March 3rd the franchise
may have flagged a bit with last year's
soft reboot men in black international
but the first three films in the MIB
series the ones which benefited from the
sure direction of barry sonnenfeld and
the otherworldly comedic chemistry of
stars Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith are
about as good as sci-fi comedies get the
first two of those 1997's men in black
and 2002's men in black 2 are available
for streaming on Netflix but not for
long if you haven't caught either of
these flicks for a while it will amaze
you to be reminded of just how fun and
funny they are especially the first one
Smith's ever inflating charisma and star
power is on full display
Jones is as cool as ever and supporting
players such as Linda Florentino the
late Rip Torn Lara Flynn Boyle and
Johnny Knoxville round out the
supporting casts of men in black and men
in black to watch them again on Netflix
until March 14th
Coraline is an innovative animated film
which everyone assumes was directed by
Tim Burton but was actually the work of
Henry Selick one of Burton's longtime
associates and director of the holiday
classic The Nightmare Before Christmas
based on a novel by master of dark
fantasy
Neil Gaiman's the mind behind the iconic
comic book series The Sandman Coraline
goes to some very unusual places not the
least of which is the alternate
dimension visited by its child
protagonist no but we need a yes if you
want to stay here so sharp you won't
feel a fit Wow basically it's a stunning
visual and narrative achievement one
which you'll want to catch again before
it's time on Netflix is up and if you've
never seen it you'll probably want to
get on that
Coraline is available to stream until
March 15th David Fincher's 2007
masterpiece zodiac is several cuts above
your average true crime thriller
meticulously researched flawlessly
written and featuring a crackerjack cast
made up largely of coincidentally future
MCU alumni the movie provides an
exhaustive examination of the zodiac
murders perhaps the most notorious
unsolved serial killings in American
history like the real-life case it's
agonizingly suggestive without providing
answers also like the case it can at
times slow to a crawl before catching
the viewer totally off-guard with
shocking punishing bursts of violence
David Fincher's Direction has never been
sharper or more deliberate stream zodiac
on Netflix until March 19th the films of
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
are some of the finest examples of the
superhero genre and they blazed more
trails than you might remember before
2005 s Batman Begins the word reboot was
used solely to describe the process of
restarting a computer Nolan's complete
revamping of Batman for the big screen
was gritty grounded and inspired even if
it took audiences forever to get their
heads around the fact that it was not a
sequel to the Tim Burton or Joel
Schumacher Batman movies it's not who I
am underneath
but what I do that defines me
the film's legacy would have been
impressive enough on its own but then
came 2008 The Dark Knight which simply
shattered everyone's notions of what a
comic book film could be sadly all good
things as they say must come to an end
Gotham's protector won't be sticking
around for much longer Batman Begins and
the Dark Knight will be available to
stream until March 30th spectacle movies
don't get much more spectacular than
Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings
trilogy and the second and third films
the two towers and Return of the King
are revered by fans of JRR Tolkien's
classic fantasy novels sure Return of
the King ends about six different times
but fans didn't mind bec the movie was
so good that they probably would have
been fine with two or three more
fake-out endings mind-blowing least aged
and perfectly cast the Lord of the Rings
flicks set a standard for big-budget
fantasy that no movie without Harry
Potter in the title has even come close
to approaching unfortunately the end is
nigh you best feast your eyes on the
final two films in the greatest fantasy
series of all time before it's too late
the Lord of the Rings the two towers and
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King will be departing Netflix on March
30th it's five sequels have provided
somewhat diminishing returns but it's
hard to overstate what a revelation
Paranormal Activity was when it hit
screens in 2007 it's inspired tweek to
the conventions of the found-footage
genre all of the action takes place on
cameras which a young couple set out
throughout their home in an attempt to
record well the Paranormal Activity
plaguing the joint allowed it to be made
on a shoestring budget this a in no way
kept it from being the scariest film of
its year and be made its 193 million
dollar worldwide box office total even
more impressive than if the film hadn't
been made for the cost of a pretty nice
used car director Oren Peli masterfully
ratchets up the tension during the
film's scant 85 minute runtime and then
unknown stars katie featherston and Nika
slow to turn in realistic performances
that make the frequent scares land that
much harder with an
third act and a final shot guaranteed to
separate you from your skin paranormal
activity is one of the very best
found-footage flicks ever made streaming
on Netflix until March 30th as a
director Quentin Tarantino is every bit
as skilled as he is wildly unrestrained
and we love him for both of those
qualities Kill Bill volume 1 and Kill
Bill volume 2 are very much two halves
of one big movie and it is part kung-fu
flick part revenge movie and all
Tarantino uma Thurman stars as Beatrix
kiddo
aka the bride a Master Assassin and once
a key member of the feared deadly Viper
assassination squad
she is brutalized and left for dead on
her wedding day by her former cohorts
including their leader bill who responds
to her plea to spare her life and the
life of their unborn child by shooting
her in the head over the course of the
two movies she exacts her revenge on the
squad's members without mercy
eventually fulfilling the flicks titles
by way of the five-point palm exploding
heart technique terrific but every once
in a while
it can be real the Kill Bill flicks are
pure distilled Tarantino which is to say
that they are uber cinematic super
stylized unbelievably violent fun they
are two of the straight-up craziest
movies you will ever see and you've only
got so much time left to see them on
Netflix Kill Bill volume 1 and Kill Bill
volume 2 will be leaving the streamer on
March 30th check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]